[Music]
all right let's do it hey what is up
guys i'm pbhd here and welcome to ask
mkbhd number 23 and it's also
12 of 12 for this year we've done one
every month january to december
and i actually kind of have enjoyed this
series a lot so far so i think if you're
down we'll probably continue it for
2018. so i asked you guys what you
wanted to know on twitter again and a
lot of you guys had some great questions
i selected some of the best of those so
uh these are those do you think tesla
will run out of money before they
release the roadster
uh that's a i don't know how people
think that i actually hear a surprising
amount of uh auto uh and industry people
who tend to think tesla is
a bubble almost they think it's gonna
rise and disappear and electric is just
a fad and they don't have to worry about
it and i think the fact that people have
been in the industry for that long and
still think that way is borderline
troubling so uh no i don't think tesla's
gonna run out of money before they
actually make the roadster i think
they'll be in a great spot by 2020.
apple just admitted it's been secretly
throttling performance of old iphones
thoughts okay so this was a really
interesting uh little
what would you call it
controversy basically apple has never
really been super transparent about it
but they've said that in order to
protect uh old batteries in old phones
so if it knows your phone has an old
battery if you have let's say you have
an iphone 6. basically apple's pushing
software updates to your phone to
eventually slow that down it's reducing
the clock speed from like 1400 megahertz
all the way down to 600 megahertz
because it knows that older batteries
have a harder time keeping up with the
high voltages it needs to keep those
high clock speeds going so technically
it makes sense that they're protecting
your user experience by slowing down
your cpu requiring less voltage and
making sure your battery lasts longer
but at the same time now all of the
headlines are hey apple is actually
pushing a software update to older
iphones to make it slow down that's not
a good look i feel like they could have
been a little more upfront and
transparent about that before it had to
be discovered with a geekbench benchmark
oh and also how convenient that there
are no removable batteries in iphones if
you actually get into an iphone and
replace the battery by opening it up and
replacing it the clock speed of the cpu
will go back to normal because it sees a
new battery bottom line i just think
it's kind of a funny controversy we all
kind of suspected this to begin with and
now it's just confirmed true i just
wouldn't be surprised if apple's not the
only one here john wants to know how has
the imac pro changed your workflow
honestly the number one thing that comes
to mind is it makes me appreciate it way
more coming from a slower machine i've
tried to edit 8k 8-1 raw videos on
macbook pros in the past and of course
my mac pro which was choking and dying
in the end of its years so the number
one difference the faster render speed
and the faster real-time playback
without dropping any frames and high
quality is the number one thing that's
made me super happy about it and the
other thing is actually in final cut pro
10.4 the new version uh there's a lot of
color controls that have replaced all of
the plugins i was using to mess with
color before in final cut and they're
all fast and optimized and i can drag as
many onto the timeline as i want and
apply them in real time and play and
there's no lag between actually hitting
the play button and it's starting to
play so i think i've been more confident
to just go in and mess with color um but
yeah no just the thing is just blazing
fast i know most of the work in final
cut pro for that rendering is being done
by the gpus by the vega gpus but i'm
also pretty excited to see how well that
18 core does when it gets here in i
think february is my ship date all right
so in supersaf's video you said your
favorite smartphone of 2017 was the
pixel 2 xl i did say that but in your
smartphone awards you said that the note
8 was the mvp
why explain yourself marquez okay so the
simple answer is i am biased and i know
i'm biased i actually value different
things than different people so i
acknowledge that i think the galaxy note
8 is the best overall most well-rounded
most complete smartphone that came out
in 2017. best screen objectively on any
phone uh has a great camera has great
performance they did a pretty great job
with the skin they get better every year
they have the stylus they have the
battery it's got a lot going for it it
kept the headphone jack but the pixel 2
has stock android which i personally
like more it's not objectively better i
just like it and the pixel 2 does have
an objectively incredible camera now it
might have a much worse screen and no
headphone jack and a bunch of other
things that aren't quite up to par
including the design but i don't really
mind that as much so i'm willing to
sacrifice that to keep that amazing
camera i know that i value the camera
more than a lot of other people who
might just want an overall complete
package that's why i pick the pixel 2
with stock android and a great camera as
my daily driver and can still
acknowledge that the galaxy note 8 is an
overall great phone because i'm biased
see how that works will 2018 be the year
of try cameras on smartphones i guess
triple cameras on smartphones no i
really don't think so in fact it'll
probably start going back to one camera
on the back just because it's actually
possible to do almost everything that we
wanted to do with dual cameras with one
as we saw from this one what would the
perfect phone setup be for you software
and hard there
what what would the perfect phone setup
be for you software and hardware and
would rather have a big sensor size or
dual camera so the whole concept of a
perfect smartphone i've been over that
in the past i actually made more than
one video about the whole idea i might
be tempted to make another one in 2018
with like these updated specs and
reference phones we have but generally
there is no perfect phone i did tweet
recently though that i would like to
have this rough combination of pixel 2
note 8 and razer phone i might not be
the only one there and as far as big
sensor or dual camera
i'm gonna go with
big sensor because you can do a lot of
the stuff like i said that you could
usually do with a dual camera with one
great camera item you most look forward
to in 2018. okay i have two two good
answers for this one is that red
smartphone uh a lot of people were
asking about it near the end of the year
for the smartphone awards whatever
happened to that red
hydrogen one that smartphone we all
pre-ordered or that i pre-ordered uh
2018 is it's expected to come out pretty
early and we expect to see more of that
probably right after ces and then two
uh accent
accent buttons on phones i've really
grown to like this colored power button
on the side of the pixel 2 and it's only
the black and white one even though it's
not the best color in the world the uh
the uh star wars oneplus 5t that does
this with that red button i really like
that too there's another huawei phone
that does this i hope 2018 is the year
of the accented power buttons or some
accent color buttons i think that's an
awesome look am i the only one is that a
weird
thing to hope for why wasn't lg v30
considered in the smartphone awards oh
it was considered trust me it was
considered it was on the desk right in
front of me
i actually said in my video about it
earlier in the year the v30 is is easily
the most underrated phone of the year
because it's a very complete phone also
across the board it's just a little bit
worse in pretty much every category than
the ones that were actually winning
awards it has a great display but not
the best display it has a great design
but not the best design it has a great
camera especially the video camera but
not the best camera it has a big battery
not the best battery life but it has a
big battery it kept the headphone jack
it has dual cameras there's a lot of
great things going for it but it's just
so underrated because it's just not
soaring above the rest in one particular
category what's your favorite winter
animal i'm gonna go with
uh
bobcat what is a winter animal
i don't know well they also are out in
the snow they're like
kills i mean they're both mountain cats
like you know they're probably happy in
the winter i think what was the point
the single event if you had to choose
one where you felt like your career as a
youtuber took off like a couple months
ago more than a year ago actually there
was a little stretch where basically vic
gundotra who was uh ahead at google for
a while uh he posted something on google
plus saying this kid is the best tech
reviewer on the planet right now and
that was awesome because i had known vic
for a while we had been sharing each
other's stuff talking and it was just a
cool thing for him to say but that quote
obviously because he was at google for a
while just kind of blew up there was
articles about it forbes article cnn
article this that everyone was writing
about it quoting him just because it was
a popular story to talk about i went on
a couple different tv news networks like
a couple different night
news shows just because of that quote
talking about it they came and they
invited me on so how old are you son and
you're doing what on the internet how is
that that's crazy he said you're the
best online so i kind of went through
those thinking like yeah no he did say
that and that's really nice of him but
this was just like one post and and
everyone sort of latched on to it and
that's like the strongest where i've
ever felt like wow is this
this is this is crazy now you never
overlook the amount of work you put into
something because it wouldn't be where
it is and if i were to go back and redo
it i probably wouldn't change anything
but i think one thing that stands out
just to answer your question is
most recently in fact up to like right
now as i'm recording this google is
running a commercial for the pixel 2 and
they're quoting a couple different like
reviews of the pixel 2 in their
commercial it's on it's playing during
like football games and nba games in
that ad spot they use quotes from new
yorktimes.com
wired.com
esquire.com
and me my review video that is honestly
mostly thanks to you guys the fact that
i can make these videos and i'm saying a
lot of the same stuff that other people
are saying in their reviews but the fact
that you guys take the advice seriously
i know is a big responsibility for me
and that's why i put all the time and
the research and the effort into making
as good of a video as possible and
that's awesome that also the companies
that are being talked about appreciate
that five out of the six companies that
won awards in that smartphone awards
video we just posted have reached out
and contacted me and asked to get their
trophies that would be essential google
razer samsung and htc i don't expect
apple to reach out for their trophy but
if they want one they can have it but
bottom line thank you to everyone for
watching i'll let you guys breathe a
little bit for the holiday season then
we'll be right back at it afterwards
with the tech stuff ces is around the
corner all these phones we're ready for
for 2018 are already starting to rumor
up so uh i'll talk to you guys then
thanks again for watching
peace
[Music]
also in case you guys are wondering
about this
this is this is part of the chris paul
bandwagon i'm not i mean i'm just saying
it now i'm allowed to follow my favorite
player so just so you know i'm not on
the
rockets bandwagon i'm on the chris paul
bandwagon